autre dossier abordé entre emmanuel
macron et vladimir poutine le conflit
armé entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
dans le haut-karabagh cinquième jour de
combats dans cette région du caucase que
les deux pays se disputent depuis 30 ans
affrontements particulièrement violents
depuis dimanche illustration avec ces
images publiées par le ministère
arménien de la défense
et si bakou et erevan semblent ignorer
les appels internationaux au
cessez-le-feu
paris et moscou sont de leur côté cette
fois sur la même longueur d'onde
la correspondance en russie dans l'omc
l'hérault les deux présidents se sont
rués au téléphone dans la soirée de
mercredi pour évoquer en priorité la
situation préoccupante dans le
haut-karabakh un communiqué publié par
le kremlin à la suite de cet appel nous
apprend que la france et la russie
appelle à un cessez le feu total et
entendent peser de tout leur poids
diplomatique pour y parvenir
vladimir poutine et emmanuel macron ont
appelé les parties au conflit à cesser
complètement le feu et dès que possible
à faire redescendre les tensions et à
montrer le maximum de retenue des appels
pour l'instant ignoré par les
belligérants qui semblent bien décidés à
en découdre d'autant que des acteurs
externes au conflit viendrait grossir
leurs rangs le ministère russe des
affaires étrangères a fait savoir que
des combattants en provenance de syrie
mais aussi de libye serait en train
d'être acheminés vers le haut karabagh
sinon sur le terrain difficile de se
faire une idée précise de ce qui se
passe réellement des informations
contradictoires sont en effet partagés
par les deux camps sur les pertes en
hommes et en matériel ou encore en
territoire une chose est sûre malgré
tout comme dans tout conflit armé ce
sont bien les populations civiles qui en
pâtissent le plus
m
c'est notre patrie nous n'avons nulle
part où aller c'est absolument hors de
question qu'ils sont eux mêmes
même si nous fuyons et que nous allons
en russie comment pourrons nous vivre
parmi les gens non c'est notre patrie la
russie ne nous laissera pas en
difficulté
seigneur vous êtes très dur à dre nadia
c'est la troisième fois qu'il se bat
nous avons participé et nous n'avions
pas peur ouais je cachais mon petit
enfant dans la cave et maintenant il se
bat c'est notre vie c'est comme ça que
font les azéri c'est triste pour les
gens ici c'est triste pour les gens là
bas mais que fait le gouvernement
je ne sais pas reste à savoir maintenant
quels effets auront les efforts
diplomatiques de la france et de la
russie mais aussi de l'union européenne
et des états unis dans une région qui
couvre ce conflit depuis près de 30 ans